il faut n'est pas coutume je vais vous
parler de samsung il ya quelques jours
vous ai fait une vidéo pour vous parler
de la potentielle mort 2 samsung liées à
ses difficultés face à la concurrence
chinoise
parce que ça me saoule mis à mal dans le
secteur des smartphones avec une
concurrence chinoise grandissante du
coup ils sont obligés de réagir et
notamment dans le milieu de gamme
s'ils veulent pas voir fondre
complètement leur part de marché sur ce
segment
ça c'était l'objet d'une précédente
vidéo aujourd'hui je vous parlais d'une
innovation majeure qui pourrait arriver
en 2019 par samsung
au niveau des écrans
[Musique]
si vous intéresser aux smartphones vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que samsung
innove énormément au niveau des écrans
fabrique des écrans et fournit beaucoup
d'entreprises sans marché déjà pour ses
propres écrans oled mais aussi pour
d'autres entreprises et notamment apple
on en parlait depuis des années et ils
l'ont présenté il ya quelques temps
après ils l'ont montré très rapidement
il sera présenté
l'année prochaine c'est le galaxy xf1
réellement qu il va s'appeler c'est un
smartphone à écran pliable
il travaillait dessus depuis 2011 et
enfin il va arriver en 2019 d'un petit
moment qu'on l'attendait sas et
d'innovation majeure parce qu'on a
toujours des smartphones avec des écrans
beaucoup plus grande en détail qui
devait toujours plus réduite donc des
écrans qui occupe une énorme partie de
la face avant
mais vous d'un moment ça va être
compliqué d'avoir des énorme pavé dans
nos poches ou dans les sacs à main du
coup l'idée c'est d'avoir des
smartphones ils pourront se plier et une
fois déplié on pourra profiter d'un
grand écran pour le multimédia samsung
continue complètement d'innover et a
présenté dans la conférence des
développeurs qu'ils aient eu lieu
il n'y a pas très longtemps trois
nouveaux écrans on à l'écran infiniti
you ça c'est votre écran c'est une
encoche en forme de u l'écran infiniti
vie qui est plus un v alors je sais
c'est pas forcément évident comme ça
lorsque je vous le décide mais pourtant
c'est un écran avec un v donc ça c'est
le but ça s'est levé et vous avez
l'écran infiniti haut c'est-à-dire un
écran avec un trou percé ici et votre
écran en gros qui est comme ça ça c'est
l'infiniti haut et vous avez le nouvel
écran infiniti pour l'instant on n'en
sait pas grand chose de plus là dessus
l'infiniti au va être présent sur le
samsung galaxy à 8 aces mais samsung
pourrait présenter encore une nouvelle
techno en 2019 qui va venir équiper ses
différents écrans l'heure pas tous les
écrans probablement dans le très haut de
gamme mais qu'on va retrouver sur les
smartphones mais aussi sur les télés et
pourquoi pas par extension sur les
tablettes vous auriez un écran sans haut
parleur sans parleurs en haussant par
leur sens côté vous n'auriez plus du
tout des haut parleurs et c'est votre
écran qui ferait office de haut parleurs
par vibration vous auriez donc un écran
qui vibre qui diffuseraient
du son aussi bien lors d'un appel et
lorsque vous garderiez une vidéo alors
comme ça ça peut paraître un peu dingue
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait sortir
pauvres en public elle l'année prochaine
alors autant sur une télé on se dit que
c'est un peu moins compliqué mais sur un
smartphone avoir pour plusieurs raisons
et ça je voulais taillé dans quelques
instants
en tout cas c'est une techno qui
pourrait être présenté dès cette année
au cs 2019
le crs 2019 on voyait trains d'ici une
petite dizaine de jours et on va aller
regarder un petit peu ce qui se passe ça
du côté samsung mais aussi un peu de
tout la tech on va aller se balader
entre les start up entre les très
grosses entreprises respectent bien les
trucs hyper cool en tout cas ce qui est
très intéressant là dedans c'est voir
que samsung fabrique des techno qu'elle
va vendre directement ensuite à d'autres
sociétés notamment pour les écrans oled
mais c'est aussi des techno qu'elles
intègrent elles directement dans ces
produits donc on peut se demander par
extension est ce que cette techno va
retrouver dans le samsung galaxy s 10 ce
qui va arriver en 2019 s'est pas
forcément sûr mais peut-être dans le
note 10 allez savoir
cette info nous vient du site saint
gobain et pourrait s'appeler oled sand
sommes dix pays alors ça peut être super
intéressant mais pour moi il y a quatre
contrainte majeure pour cette techno en
tout cas soit un vrai succès sur les
smartphones la première il faut qu'elle
soit imperceptible c'est à dire que
lorsque vous allez à votre smartphone
dans la main lorsque vous aller naviguer
vous avez une vidéo
votre écran ne doit pas bouger vous fait
pas sentir de vibrations au niveau de
votre doigt donc ça doit être
complètement transparent c'est une
vibration de l'écran mais vous ne devez
en aucun moment où vous rencontrez cran
vibre le deuxième point c'est la
confidentialité parce que ce qui est
très important c'est lorsque vous allez
prendre de smartphones et lorsque vous
allez téléphoner avait donc le son va se
propager par vibration l'écran il faut
absolument pas que par soi qu'il soit
autour de vous même dans un
environnement très silencieux puisse
capter ce que vous êtes en train de dire
parce que j'imaginais que vous ayez un
truc hyper hyper hyper personnel et très
chaud qu'on puisse pas à côté entendre
donc du fait que ça s'apprend vibrason
l'écran il faut absolument pas qu'on
puisse les capter troisième point et non
des moindres elle la qualité la qualité
audio doit être au moins identique voire
meilleure que celle qu'on va voir avec
des haut-parleurs des haut parleurs déjà
éprouvée qu'on connaît sur d une qualité
audio qui est moins salvo absolument pas
le coup
r l'idée d'avoir un des bras sion du
fait de l'écran on doit profiter d'une
meilleure qualité audio et d'une
meilleure spatialisation que quatrième
point c'est le prix s'il fait que cette
techno sont intégrés au roulement
vraiment le coût de votre smartphone je
vois plus trop l'intérêt parce que vous
avez des hauts parleurs qui marche
aujourd'hui effectivement c'est une
nouvelle techno ça devrait en tout cas
apporter un mieux mais si ça fait
vraiment augmenter l'addition et si les
smartphones continuent à être encore
plus cher deux par set techno
j'ai bien peur que ce soit un petit peu
par en tout cas très intéressant mais si
samsung réussi sur ces quatre points à
mon avis ça pourrait être vraiment une
technologie révolutionnaire donc à une
techno qui devrait cambrai standard et
permettrait à samsung de continuer à
gagner de l'argent parce que forcément
là dessus il ya un brevet et si d'autres
marques veulent utiliser elles vont
devoir payer en tout cas c'est très
intéressant avec ce point là c'est qu'on
voit que samsung continue toujours être
entreprises qui innovent notamment au
niveau des écrans mais pas que on en
parle beaucoup parce qu'on parle de
smartphones et c'est vraiment un point
qui m'intéresse énormément mais elle
innove sur beaucoup de points et même si
elle un peu plus de mal dans le milieu
de gamme au niveau des smartphones a
trouvé sa place par pour une concurrence
chinoise était très très très très très
forte et que ça devient extrêmement
difficile d'ailleurs elle n'est pas la
seule
même si c'est extrêmement difficile elle
continue à innover complètement au
niveau des écrans au niveau des écrans
avec du son intégrée au niveau des
écrans pliables au niveau de plein de
techno et ça c'est super intéressant
donc ce que je vous invite à faire c'est
à vous abonner parce que le csj seraient
des sites quelques jours je vous emmène
avec moi dans mes bagages
on va les voir ce qui s'y trame on va
les voir les nouvelles technos val
essayer de sentir un petit peu de capter
un peu ce qui va se passer en 2019 voire
un peu plus loin 2020 2021
et puis il ya des prochaines vous allez
voir ça va être hyper intéressant va y
avoir plein de déplacement il ya le cs
on va aller offert aussi un tour du côté
de londres en janvier
j'en parle pas plus pour le moment vous
verrez ça va être hyper cool on va les
voir plein de choses intéressantes on
ira bien évidemment au mobile world
congress pour aller voir les nouveautés
100% smartphones enfin y avoir un truc
complètement dingue en 2019 mais ça on
en reparle très prochainement
d'ici quelques jours il invite donc à
vous abonner à rester connectés
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt
ciao